I had the dream which at that time
seemed totally impossible to be a writer
because I I enjoyed reading so much that
I had the idea that life concentrated to
tell stories to invent stories would be
something absolutely fantastic but it
seemed impossible because at that time
there were no many Latin Americans who
were only writers so the writers that I
I knew we're writers only for holidays
or for weekends they were professional
there were lawyers there were diplomats
who had their life completely
consecrated to different you know
professions and and that people who
practice literature as a hobby as an
eventual hobby and I didn't want to be a
writer only of Sundays and holidays and
so my dream at that time was to be a
writer but it seemed something
impossible you know then I discovered
that it was a city in the world in which
apparently it was possible to be only a
writer and that was Paris so since I was
very young I had the idea that I should
organize my life in order to reach Paris
because in Paris it was possible to be
only a writer and in fact and in fact
something of the sort happened to me
because when I finished University I
studied to be a lawyer and at the same
time for pleasure humanities and then
when I finished University I got a grant
to make doctorate in Spain in Madrid so
I was in Madrid a year and a half and
then I moved to Paris and finally in
Paris I could organize my life in order
to not only to be exclusively a writer
but to got jobs that let me free time to
write and to read and so it was in Paris
that I became a professional writer as I
had thought when I was a boy and I lived
seven seven years in Paris working as a
journalist well as a teacher first then
as a journalist but there were jobs that
gave me a lot of free time so I could
consecrate most of my my time to to
write which I was very lucky because
that's what I was longing since I was
very young to write books to write
novels to write short stories to write
place
I thought that was the most
extraordinary activity in the in the
world you know and and it was
embarrassing
in a way that I could organize more and
more my my life with enough free time in
order to consecrate most of my time tool
to writing him yeah I finished my first
novel there my second novel and I was
writing my third novel when I moved from
Paris to London where I went to teach
and teaching in in in a London
University was something very pleasant
because I thought literature Latin
American and Spanish literature and it
was a kind of job that led me a lot of
free time for writing now so I can say
that I I really became a real writer in
Paris in London in Europe